We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P.,
one of our viewers is very
worried. Take a listen to.
A David Pakman Tom is from Austin, right?
Hey, man, I have to really tell you,
I am a gay man, OK?
And I have noticed that your
complexion is starting to turn very white.
I don't know the election and you're staying
inside and doing your research.
But, man, get your vitamin D
because we have to see a sexy young
progressive tan or whatever you call yourself.
All right.
The Jewish whatever.
We have to have that in our progressive field.
So young man looking a little pale in my opinion.
OK, I appreciate the comments. Can you believe
this is my job? I appreciate the concern.
I am making it a point of spending time outside
every single day. It's been unseasonably warm
lately. I've been biking, I've been running. I
had my vitamin D checked and it's looking pretty
strong. That was right at the end of winter. I
did that. And if at the end of winter my D was OK,
you would think my vitamin D level would be OK
now, but I'm going to keep on it. I appreciate
the concern. We've got a great bonus show for
you today. We are going to talk about where
do the what what we are calling Trump is dead
enders on the election. Where are they going now?
What media are they consuming? We will talk about
Donald Trump's firing of his secretary of defense
and we will talk about Vladimir Putin's hesitation
to congratulate Joseph R. Biden Jr.. All of those
stories and more on the bonus show. Get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom. If you want a massive
discount, use the coupon code fresh start.
That coupon code will save you an ungodly
amount off of membership when you sign up.
I'll see you on the bonus show.